let's switch it on let's see what it
does through this coil of thick wire
we're about to pass a huge alternating
electric current on top is a 1 kilogram
aluminium plate so we hear this noise
what's that noise is the vibration of
the plate because it's we're waiting at
the two times the frequency of the son
of difference 1 whoa whoa how does it do
that to find out I've come to the place
where it all started the Royal
Institution in London this is the key to
Faraday's magnetic lab amazing that
locks to work from day seen $70 became a
storeroom which is why it survived and
it survived intact all the joinery
chocolate row magnet exactly the same as
Faraday so this is exactly as Faraday
would have perhaps what yep in Faraday's
time it was known that electric current
creates a magnetic field but it remained
an open question whether the reverse is
possible if a magnetic field could
generate electric current Faraday
answered this question with his most
famous apparatus father's
electromagnetic induction ring which is
this in August 1831 Faraday wrapped two
coils of insulated wire around this iron
ring but 1831 you could not go down to
your local that hardware shop and aspect
centimeters in safety while you had to
in say the wire as you went and so as
you pushed and pulled the wire about the
ring you had to insulate it it takes 10
working days which is a huge investment
of time but the investment paid off when
Faraday connected a battery to one of
the coils he saw a brief pulse of
current in the other coil and when he
disconnected the battery he saw a pulse
of current in the other direction
he realized that current was induced in
the second coil only when the magnetic
field through it was changing and if
they hadn't been wrapped on the same
ring
Faraday may have noticed that the two
coils repel each other when the current
is induced and that's due to the
interaction of their magnetic fields
which brings us back to this through the
bottom coil we are passing a huge
electric current 800 amps which
alternates in Direction 900 times per
second this ensures there will always be
a changing magnetic
field above the coil instead of a second
coil we're using the aluminium plate but
the principle is the same the changing
magnetic field induces currents in the
plate that create an opposing magnetic
field so it levitates ha ha ha how
awesome is this this current is not only
good for levitating the plate they can
also make light bulbs glow the gift oh
thank you oh that is go look too close
because it's here we
can I put it there yep and just as
current in a toaster element heats it up
the induced current in the plate
dissipates its energy as heat if you
have yet to see them check out how hot
this plate is oh that is nuts
is this your favorite demo they could
say about the cool tell me this is not
the best dinner table centerpiece it
levitates it gives you light and you can
cook on it and all the while you're
demonstrating Faraday's law of
electromagnetic induction where do I get
that matter to grow this we can save the
grain steps or any goodness you have
those ions in it it means we can break
down a greater distance of air goodness
it's pretty conductivity why isn't there
a big hole around the tree where it's
taking out over soil there's this a
gradually let the soil has time to
recover